we are back samisen and studio and
really rooting for me to [ __ ] up with
the mics but I think I got them all the
pressures on I did a good job you did a
great job
I just wanted to slow down so I wanted
to hear a little bit of this [ __ ] uh
you don't have to make excuses oh boy is
that good is this the new Kendrick it is
good alright that's all super notch by
Black Sabbath oh alright well welcome
back Sam we waited for you because I
forgot you and I texted Oh could you
because I always just think about the
pictures that we sent each other on
Instagram I am I see by the way the
tough crowd video I put up last night I
put it up last night at probably 10 p.m.
and it's got 30,000 views already on
Twitter so that people really do want to
see the show again and we're [ __ ]
Colin and vault we are dumb if we don't
figure out a way to at least do a few
live shows you can test the waters just
do a tough crowd podcast
I mean if Colin if you can get away with
using the term tough crowd
Colin hosting a podcast with like I mean
I know it's like kind of the thing
that's done but if you can format it the
way tough crowd was formatted you know I
think a tough crap I can't with really
really learn Network or maybe some you
know some streaming thing there's so
much out there I can get it wouldn't it
because it would a podcast wouldn't it
was a great idea but I think it's it
would do better on video just because I
think you said so many shows are doing
that kind of podcast like Bobby's pot
you know wherever it is a bunch of guys
talking yeah I would have to be like
very it would be very introduced yeah it
would have to be like a very produced it
had to be a podcast that was produced
like a TV show in the sense that there
were segments and Sounders and intros
and bubble it felt good about tough
crowd was the fact that mistakes were
made with the fact that it wasn't smooth
and pretty in Colin was not a perfect
host he was like he would trip on words
or we would bomb on jokes and Colin
would make them leave the bombs in there
but I was a part of what made the show
work do when he would he would give up
on a joke in the middle
it would just be like I knew that one
wouldn't work we even finish it it would
work better now than it did then because
it's cheap to produce and you could you
could divide up those into clips I can't
believe the politics is why it would be
tough but the politics is kind of wipe
some people would love it it would be
love young people would love it but
networks are even less likely now to
take anything that's not kind of liberal
politically the YouTube might take it
you come if you HBO wouldn't touch it
really no and neither will Comedy
Central Netflix I don't even know if
they would touch it maybe hulu hulu
might or but it would have to be one of
those things where we were within reason
allowed to say we wanted to say because
some people were always annoyed by the
show
yeah but anyone who's really gonna
invest in it is gonna get the best part
of the show don't also you have a lot of
people different people tell them
different views it's not that never
mattered conserve yeah we got a lot of
[ __ ] even back then they don't like ya
they like everybody telling the same
point of view you know from the same
like when you watch The Daily Show it's
not like you have this wide variety of
opinions right every late-night show has
the exact same take on everything many
different personalities and different
jokes but how is everyone on late-night
television 100% on the same side of the
fence it's embarrassing because they
watched it work for one guy they were
like oh my god how did Colbert become
like last place - first place and now
everybody's kind of following suit this
is what we do it would be it would be so
great to do this it made me really
pumped up to do it again we I had no
idea what's happening and we went out
and it was just an hour it was Colin and
backstage we literally all four it
sounds to all of us literally want to
cry backstage but it was just weird to
have done that with with the top of the
roundest Washington minute I'm sorry no
I cried during the entire thing but it
was a weird thing to have just done that
that could again I've done podcast panel
shows and all that but to have done that
with him and to see the tough crowd logo
up again it was like [ __ ] we just kind
of ripped that for an hour especially
with the amount of love you guys must
have gotten for it it was great yeah key
what I hated that he would have yes he
would have liked you guys to pre-plan
but we used to actually write jokes out
oh yeah it was it was a funny show
although I mean that classic clip of
Leary
Geraldo and Leo that was amazing we
thought that was an insult you prepare
yeah
[ __ ] TV show yeah what was
funny that the guys who would go on
there like it seems so loose and like
you could do whatever but you had to
have I mean dump Patrice would never
write his jokes down but he was you know
he was a good enough talker sure he
would have pre everyone had to have
stuff because you were with for
comedians talking about the same subject
way it's also like your time television
show right like you kind of have you
can't just make it up as you go because
you can't afford that much room to bomb
like you can't [ __ ] up an entire episode
because nobody's got anything at the
spur of the moment you don't got the
Kathy Griffin if you're sitting on a
panel with [ __ ] Patrice and Nick and
Geraldo and you're all gonna be talking
about ok Bush did this yeah
and you you're with those guys and Colin
and I think you're just gonna go up like
you better have something fun you better
have a couple of layers written because
Greg's gonna hit an angle Nick's gonna
hit an angle Patrice caught everyone get
me firing [ __ ] so you have to have stuff
or at least ideas of what you want to
say because if you think you're just
gonna riff and have better jokes than
those guys you're crazy what I thought
was nice was that even when Colin would
slip on a word or two is the host did
you slip you guys as the panelists would
kind of just let him go why just support
him like fun you wouldn't want to point
it out it was so fun to leave the
weeklies to have to submit certain
things like for third and fourth act
things had to be what go through
standards and practices like the skits
and stuff like that those always worry
yeah but once in a while we would have a
thing where Colin would give us a quiz
or whatever and it would be rift or just
improv that other times we would have it
so one time I submitted this thing that
wasn't particularly good it was a pacman
joke like the game huh and in the joke
III made the pac-man sound well you know
two thousand three or four pac-man
wasn't at its height of popularity I
don't remember if you looked at up a
page I might even be out there and it
didn't do well I'm very embarrassed any
commitment when you're not an act out
comic and you commit and it doesn't work
it's
the word feelings break is this you're
out of your comfort zone anyway it's a
it's a weird feel like I'm being kind of
vulnerable I'm going for that sound
effect and they just stare at you you're
like this is why I don't do it a video
school for you were you just like
looking at the camera and making this
joke to camera no to Colin
I hope you could find excite really want
to hear this back it's not just Colin
Colin knew it was coming
oh boy did and he didn't stop you from
that this is how beautiful that show was
that in the back room you submitted a
joke that he knew wasn't gonna work and
he didn't say a word
no go to Jim Norton tough crowd you try
pac-man that it's funny that it's his
own show and he's encouraging someone to
eat gonna work and he's like yep you did
that because I remember when I was a
teenager I was arrested for painting my
face yellow and running around yelling
what go walk off after playing pacman
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Reese what it made air no that came up
pretty quick the beauty that show though
that you would just address the bomb
like every other show so overproduced
now you address the bomb it was sloppy
that because it was it was honest it
tried it tried to be when we tried to
make it honest which is comedies not
always beautiful there's times where you
trip on it there's times where it's ugly
it's flawed it is what it is I always
thought it was like you know just as a
viewer I was like Comedy Central is
finally doing a show where comedians get
to be comedians I was like that this is
the show that should be the purpose of
the network at the time yeah I mean
right and the fact is we were on right
after The Daily Show
I think refer to The Daily Show [ __ ]
that was fun so people if people like
again the video I posted with that was
that was a great hour TV man that's like
when Jon Stewart was like locked into
that was a good hour man oh you know
what's funny just said that could we get
an hour last night tougher we just yeah
but it's only a 30 minute show the only
ever 30 minutes it was 22 minutes with
commercials there's no way we couldn't
[ __ ] bang out an amazing 22 minutes
it would be funny and a lot of people
would be angry by the takes people would
take but I think we should have try it
again it's like we've talked about it
for years why not what else we don't
especially as the easy as it is to now
create your own content and find a venue
for it yeah
and Colin was so funny last night as the
host just off the cuff I mean you know
just so funny no writers nothing because
he had writers you had to write for the
monologue holy
we maki and i can't officially announce
this but we can tease it that we might
roast battle each other on Comedy
Central
just to see just a team he said we could
tease it so we might roast battle each
other now I can't confirm or deny those
those those vicious rumors then be seen
yeah are you are you worried that it
would bring down your level of celebrity
I don't want to be associated with yeah
I understand I see that's good yeah
that's good I'm gonna dig way deeper
than Rachel Maddow a Hannah gasps [ __ ]
yeah are you really gonna make it hurt
hey so I'll be saying I was waiting for
you too because I did you and I texted a
little bit like chums will do that's
right but we the I did watch Hannah
Gatsby's Nannette which is never
explained why 9 that was the name of the
show
all she said in the beginning of the
show was that she named it in the net
after a person that she was dating at
the time she said I named it in the net
before I had actually written the hour
and it was after a woman that I was
dating at the time who I thought oh
she's so interesting this is gonna be
easy to get an hour out of and that
didn't happen but she didn't change the
name I wonder if there's something that
cutout of the special like I was just
started with that and I think that it's
not gonna be related to the show but she
named the show a certain thing before
she wrote the hour but before the
special is aired you could have I don't
know I thought that it fell out there
was something that was incomplete about
that just the title you mean yeah we we
we saw the you know we watched it
because so many people had opinions on
it you know comedians were saying and if
anyone who thinks it's the death of
comedy that's what I have not read
anything on this I haven't read her
interviews any writer who has said this
is the death of comedy
you're a stupid mother yeah Charlie true
yeah go see Joe Mackie if you think
comedies dead oh yeah cuz you'll prove
you wrong bye bye Joe
I can't say don't know don't know what
we should do is try to get it down here
before Jeff Ross has a chance I totally
agree I think but to safe the death of
calm it was again I liked it a lot more
than I thought I would but it did
nothing it has not changed comedy at all
it was an interesting thing that she did
and it's definitely worth watching it
does feel like a one-person show towards
the end of it there's things about it I
would have preferred she didn't do but
it's fall it's just a comedy special
that has a one person show vibes at the
end of it so if anything he expanded the
genre not detracted because people don't
know how to watch something and like
because she's talking about in early on
she's doing I might have to quit comedy
because I need to tell my story and it
was like to look she had some horrible
[ __ ] happen to her being [ __ ] a
lesbian in this Tasmania that's crap and
being told it was criminal there and all
this self-hatred and she was talking
about how self deprecation is not
humility it's humiliation so she might
have to quit comedy because she can't
tell her story she feels like it's
selling her story short but the reality
is you don't have to do self deprecation
know for some people works and for
others it's like do whatever kind of
comedy you want to [ __ ] do no there's
no comedy Bible right you could talk
about all of these stereotypes about
being gay or looking male or the shitty
way you were treated or men being abused
without self deprecating of course you
don't have to self deprecated it's joke
the joke can be on the people doing it
to you you don't have to put the joke
back on yourself yeah and she was saying
that the joke she said one thing that
was very it was brilliant but then it
flawed her ending she did a whole thing
in art history which I thought was great
like it was very original talking about
a Picasso was kind of a piece of [ __ ]
and you know she knew what she was
talking about not a commonly covered
subject no and so I respected it I'm
like its original anybody who didn't
like like she's a very original person
it was very personal I kind of wish
she'd peppered in him a few punchlines
in there at some point in the Picasso
thing I felt like she was doing a show
for herself
a little bit yeah it does like when I
start talking about wrestling and
everybody's like we've lost the
universal appeal of this same man he
starts thrashing Ellijay he's
I don't heart he went to trash analogy
for man I don't like any kind of prank
stuff doesn't mean you're you and your
best friend go around insulting each
other and you don't like people telling
the truth so yeah it was the whole the
whole thing I felt she could have put
some because she was saying that you say
I have to tell my story and I can't like
these things I want to talk about in my
act now and I can't because I can't make
them funny yet there's certain things I
have not talked about because they're
not funny to me yet
not in a self-righteous way I just
haven't found the thing that just right
just go onstage one night and it works
so I can't talk about it because who
gives a [ __ ]
if I'm talking about my life if I can't
make it funny as a comedian but couldn't
couldn't hand it just write a book write
up what I mean like do comedy and also
tell your story you don't have to it's
not like comedians get 60 minutes to
tell their story and it better be funny
and that's the only communication you're
gonna get with an audience I haven't
seen the special I don't I don't care
what like if you if that's what you want
you're it's your special if that's what
you want your special to be I just don't
like when people are like this is comedy
now words right it's got to be that now
there can be jokey specials like a piano
falls on a guy's head it's always funny
so I think is always funny yeah but she
talked about like how the story how the
laughter I guys comedy would kind of
degrade the point of the story but
that's not the truth no I don't like
these rules yeah and I think
self-deprecating humor empowering
sometimes it can be ya know so I don't
know if that's a universal truth that
self-deprecation is is it it's
belittling her experience I I'm for me
and I don't know when you wit when maybe
that's her reality maybe that could be
her but I think it's reality probably I
was I have a girl like Trevor Noah's
story like well that guy's had a crazy
[ __ ] life yeah you know I can't ever
imagine what his life has been like so
yeah maybe for people like that maybe it
is belittling but for like me it's I I
love self-deprecating jokes like I
haven't had the experiences she had but
I like making jokes about my like my
beer you know stupid beer gutter or
whatever because it makes if it makes
you feel a little more relieved to
acknowledge
and just to have it out there and if her
if she doesn't feel that way anymore you
don't have to do your act does not have
to be self deprecation it can be about
the insanity of society to feel that way
or it can be about the ignorance of
other people
you don't have to and I sent Sam a clip
like like people who tell their story
and a tragic story and are funny
resonate far more than somebody who just
preaches at you
I don't need hair kind of did it you
know yeah that's the clip was and I'm
not and I'm not gonna edit the name of
is the album is called bicentennial
[ __ ] it's 1976 oh my god nervous can
you please dump and it's uh it's a
really sarcastic really sarcastic
statement about America and black people
and it's just dripping with [ __ ] anger
and he's disgusted and he gets laughs
through the entire [ __ ] yeah peace
and you know exactly what the challenge
well that's the net was the name of the
bit it was the final bit on that record
it's not his funniest bit but when you
talk about it taking painful things and
making them funny he didn't need to
drill the message home with a stop all
kidding aside ladies and gents right the
bit was funny from point A to point B
and when you listen to it against two
minute bit you're like like it was a
really really heavy way to close a
comedy album in 1976 and so if that's
how he told the story and I've heard
that for forty years and and the power
of that has resonated with me for forty
I never once felt like I was preached
that I knew exactly what he was saying I
knew exactly what he meant by it and he
didn't have to stop in your arm no more
laughter here let me sit you down and
tell you exactly right that's actually
like it's almost like we're being talked
at sometimes with these jokes you know
it's like it's almost like we're being
shown and not told I made me told him
that shown rather to play devil's
advocate though I do think that if
there's flaws in the comedy special
that's you could say that about any
comedy special but yeah I agree with
what you're saying that it's almost like
we got to pause the comedy show here for
a second why not do the comedy I would
say to play devil's advocate
what is your longest race
yeah I thought that like multiple times
not even just in the end multiple times
her special kind of drifted into a TED
talk where it was she was just telling
her story without jokes and like you
said talking at people and like getting
up on her on her podium and letting
everybody know that this is right she is
right you are wrong and she also went on
this thing that bothers me just on a
logic level on an intellectual level
where you know she's making fun of like
men and white guys and stuff like that
which is fine sure but she said
specifically she was like and if you
think I'm persecuting you are well if
you think I'm persecuting you I am
because you know I went I'm telling all
these stories about how I've been
persecuted and multiple of all the
groups I associate with have been
persecuted so you can take it for an
hour and I've always like I get it but
I've also always and she's right that
like white guys need to be able to take
a joke about white guys mm-hmm but the
idea that you should persecute the
people to persecute you it's like if it
was bad when they did it to you why
would you turn around and do it to them
I didn't feel like it was a kind of
persecuted what was interesting about it
was I thought it was a funny thing when
she was saying how people tell you I'll
just take a joke take a joke and then
she turned around and did all these
callbacks using them against white males
the things that she's been told I was
tied it in with you need a good [ __ ]
yeah I thought it was hilarious when she
did that she said what you say jizz oh
yeah yeah yeah
Oh awesome cheers whatever I thought it
was great so uh you know I enjoyed the
special a lot more than I thought and
she did things that I didn't think she
needed to do yeah yeah I thought that
yeah I mean there were moments it almost
felt like she wasn't that experienced
with the material or with comedy in
general or with what she really wanted
to do because the message it's not a bad
message you can get the message out
there but I felt like the most important
points started getting lost on me yep
because I didn't mind
she was being funny like it wasn't the
funniest comedian I've ever seen but it
was comedy like it wasn't somebody it's
like how the [ __ ] did you get on Netflix
it was like okay like this is sure is
some of the jokes were cute or whatever
but when she wanted to drive home the
important points by yelling and being
angry about it and just I was like it's
getting lost on me because it's not
being delivered with any like poignancy
it's not being delivered with a
different spin it's not like turning
people's minds it's just listing things
that are bad right that anybody watching
that special would be like yeah like I
thought those were bad walking in I
don't I think punching lesbians is a bad
thing to do when you hear did a lesbian
gets the [ __ ] kicked out of her I think
everybody watching that special is going
like yeah that's horrible but I'd you
know I've thought it was horrible when
Matthew Shepard told his when the
Matthew Shepard sure he was told you
know decades ago he was the good standup
though even though he was so he was good
yeah but he's after 10 minutes he really
was like the same thing over so it's
like no Jeremy Piven that's where it's
like if we all already think this is bad
what are we accomplishing here like what
do tell your story I just feel like with
snare Ivan again I haven't seen the sale
watch it this week but it's like that
thing where now jokes don't sell a
special it almost feels like you gotta
have some hooks something something very
unique and original but she said
something very very contradictory yeah
she goes at one point she was talking
about art she made a brilliant point
where she said artists don't create the
zeitgeist they respond to it which was
an amazingly it was a very good point
because that is what art is what comedy
is now you're not creating the world
it's what reporters are supposed to do I
believe Jeremy Jeremy Piven said it very
well when he said hug it out [ __ ]
that's right that's right but at the end
of the special she was talking about how
comedians have a responsibility and if
comedians had done that job during
Monica Lewinsky instead of making her
the punchline maybe we would not have
gotten a man elected today which she was
saying if comedians had done their jobs
and not made fun of Monica they had made
fun a bit with first of all I was doing
stand-up when Clinton happened comedians
made fun of Bill Bill Clinton I mean
from got murdered by comedians so did
Monica but Bill Clinton got
my comics and then she's saying if
comedians had done their jobs properly
maybe Trump wouldn't have got that was
basically the push of it comedians
really get a lot of the political
pressure these days for retiring be
honestly you know you guys are stand-ups
yes none of you started stand-up comedy
because you wanted to be more
responsible because you were like oh I
want to be responsible in my life I'm
gonna be a comedian you know but it's
not our job I wanted Ross Perot to have
a better campaign you did that's not my
[ __ ] job now of course not I got my
job to teach the Sheep my to lead people
to educate people that mean you're on my
jungle scientists well it's not my job
as a comic right it's not my job is to
make you walk away learning something
about a lesson teacher it's our job to
respond to the zeitgeist I got it that
was a great way for her to put it though
artists do respond to it we don't create
it
that's what comedians are not supposed
to be creating the [ __ ] so don't
don't don't say that about artists and
let them off the hook and then all of a
sudden act like comedians our job is to
change culture it's not she also started
in this to me was hypocritical she
started by saying you know what do you
identify as what do you identify as and
she goes at this point I just identify
as tired yeah I was like that's great
yeah yeah and it's like I think a lot of
people feel that way like enough of like
figuring out what the label is for this
and who are you and what are you and
blah blah but then it's frustrating to
hear the cheadle like labeled all white
guys as something because we're also
putting a label on its if she afters
analyzing every I didn't mind that I
don't care people make fun of white guys
it's a guy but after after that joke I
find when they make fun of all white
white people as being the same thing or
all black people as being the same thing
or all Asian women or you know whenever
you say this whole group is going yeah I
name more groups like it's silly to say
that all people of this group behave
exactly the same right but after that
joke of I identify is tired mm-hmm like
everything is identity politics the
whole thing is about identity politics
and you're like why would you start
well maybe she went in with the joke it
sounds like at least he going with a
joke
yeah but the joke doesn't it the joke is
contradictory to what the whole spin you
know what to what the spin of the
specialist I don't mind that in comedy I
don't mind like I don't I care more
about the jokes than I do the message
like well yeah or the consistency right
like I want to cuz we're all hypocrites
yeah that's but you I think you yeah you
can you can joke your way out of being a
hypocrite if you're just telling jokes
right but when you stop telling jokes oh
yeah and you're like what I thought are
we waiting these statements and
statements right are we just listening
to jokes and being funny like I turned
on Tom Segura's special after this
special and I was like oh no this is
this is what I'm supposed to feel
special it's hilarious
I think the funny I haven't seen her
special but I think if she placed that
joke at the end of a bunch of identity
politics jokes it would have been better
yes totally it's just gotta be there has
to be jokes or sores and then with jokes
well it's something else just call it
something else but it doesn't it's not
changing comedy now it's being
mislabeled yes I think it is a comment
she's a legit comedian it's a legit
special there completely yeah there's no
well you're not sitting there going like
this shouldn't be on Netflix they
shouldn't be labeled comedy this
shouldn't call it whatever you want but
let's not pretend that like the genre is
changing and that everybody for comedy
now has to have what are your statements
that you're ending your your special
with books Sam Gemini's success and
failure isn't going to be determined by
one other person's special right no
every but people just oh yeah you can't
name your special man that now that's
kind of a bummer
wow that was a walk-up no I thought it
wasn't a bad name it was like that's
kind of funny you know I know people
people do it did this happen I don't
know hello Peter in Canada good how he
had but I was just curious if you guys
thought the rise of the shows like The
Daily Show The Colbert Report all those
comedy fake news shows do you think they
have something to do with putting
comedians in a different light and now
sometimes comedians take themselves more
seriously than they did you
ten years ago um all right thanks Peter
I don't know I think there's something
to that I mean I think that you know
timing of everything that coupled with
social media and the idea of just
people's opinions like people thinking
that their opinions on things right
matter way more and and will you seek
comics getting like a lot of press and
getting a lot of credit for being the
voice of this group or look at this
person breaking the mold or whatever so
you almost lose sight I could see a
young comic watching the route that some
people take losing sight of the fact
that this game is supposed to be just
about telling the funniest jokes you can
tell because they're watching other
people succeed on being the voice of
this disenfranchised group or even if
you're not a member of that group I'm
gonna speak for this I'm gonna come from
that point of view without thinking
about what are the jokes being right is
more important than being funny right to
a lot of people I think when The Daily
Show started it was a lot of pure
comedians like guys like Steve Carell
and Stephen Colbert and karela stand-up
but like you know as time goes on yeah I
guess it's like maybe there's like a
self-righteousness which to me is like
the death of comedy like you got to be
funny the original when Jon Stewart
first start doing the Daily Show with
all those guys a lot of it it wasn't
just let's bash Republicans liberal
liberal a lot of it was absurdist comedy
yeah you know a lot of great comics who
still do that you know I was one of my
favorite comics you know yeah but there
is definitely you know a in comedy there
being funny is still just the most
important thing to a lot of comics and
then there's these comics who care about
being right you know and and that is the
death of of comedy with boring who gives
a [ __ ] if you're right right who cares
you know the thing that separates a
comic from somebody who's not a comic
everyone has a story yeah how many
people have sad stories so with the
thing that separates us is we have the
ability to tell these stories or talk
about these things and make you laugh
about them
whatever angle we choose to take like
the great Rupert Pupkin yes yes we take
the terrible awful things in our life
and somehow turn them into comedy that's
it but I mean that technically is a
great that is what it is
just taking
terrible awful things in my life and
discussing them is not necessarily stand
up it can be a one-person show that's
very compelling and very inspirational
and very interesting and that's all
great sure people give talks that's fair
right nothing wrong with it but I think
the you know Cullen makes a good point
there it's like they were there I think
those shows definitely influenced you
know the way comedy for the better and
worse will will be influenced over time
like Animal House you know great comedy
but think about all the shitty movies
that came after that trying to recreate
that when you try to recreate the exact
same thing that's not what I think
happens over time it does yeah a great
when you just keep doing the same thing
that [ __ ] comedy up well the whole
house was a shitty movie - I'm just
trying to keep insulting things that
everyone likes I think you're right
though I mean it's it launched a number
of great comedians careers how could it
not influence people
yeah but then people try to redo it but
they try to redo it without what made it
great which was catching you off-guard
or doing something that you're like holy
[ __ ] I think Sam might had a tweet where
it's a lot of Kim's first credit is an
article about politics and the New York
Times or something well yeah well it's
like it used to be like you want to get
on like Conan or The Tonight Show or
something and now comics like I see like
like you've you've seen this guy in an
article in the New York Times you know
yeah okay that's not a comedy outlet
yeah and people want certain people
start praising something other people
don't want to come out and go yeah it's
good but there's this angle you know
right um but they're saying that it
changed comedy no you could say you
loved it but it didn't change I didn't
make comedy worse didn't make it better
it was just it's a different unique
special sheeted yeah that I would hope
people don't try to mimic because that
can get annoying because whatever you're
talking like lettuce beer if you want to
break down the honesty of anything when
you're doing a one-hour planned
performance the emotion is even planned
not planned like it's not fake but you
know where the emotional points are
coming you're gonna figure out where to
where to hit it
sure I'm gonna put a laugh here because
over here I'm gonna get really angry and
over here I'm gonna get really sad yeah
because that's just the way the story is
told right so if telling your story and
knowing where the sad points are going
to be and knowing where it's going to
and kind of knowing that you're taking
people on an emotional rollercoaster if
that's okay why is having laughter in
there not okay well here's the risk -
don't you think that and I don't know
but don't you think that just telling
your story is way easier than making
jokes about your story well I like
knowing that like like isn't it isn't
gonna be easier if comics think that
they can get away that's a good that's a
good special Tyler with their my story
right in my store wouldn't it be easier
for a young comic to like just go up
there and tell their story without jokes
yeah it's like uh-oh is uh his parents
died in a car accident who was - that's
gonna be a great bit thing about
lagrosse to me now is like when you hear
these rows these comics like go at each
other and it's like this setup to the
joke is like the most [ __ ] up thing
they're like his his mother died in a
car crash and you're like oh my god this
is what we're going yeah it's it's
almost like rows have become this thing
where people are gonna find the most
horrible [ __ ] they can say about you
with someone but if they're friends it's
like one thing but if you don't know the
person or whatever happened to surface
like when do you have a big nose yeah no
dude that goes back to my theory about
people nowadays when you're allowed to
be mean you just it's a hundred times
worse because they're so few there's so
many fewer spots where people are
socially acceptable to be mean now as
opposed to like you know when tough
crowd was on the air for example that
now when it's a roast or when you find a
villain on the news that you can go
after you just go don't feel that way
because like on Twitter people will say
[ __ ] that's just like insane but only
anonymously that's true right like no
but like you wouldn't go and say
something crazy on Twitter yeah I got
insulted by somebody's screen name was
but lick or something seriously just
tried to get the most personal answer oh
man today but liquor 44 really they hurt
my feelings
did you like I liked her special more
than I thought I would III it was
funnier than I thought I would like
because I heard all these think
comedians are killing it and I'm like
wow this must be awful but I was like
that she's a good comic it was just at
the end heard the choice she made I wish
make my ended up like him more than I
thought I would just because mark
Normand was so against it had he seen it
or no no no he hasn't seen it is not
seen isn't ration it to me by this and
I'm like you ever even seen this that's
why we told him you can come back on the
show after you watch the special because
we're all gonna watch it so yes I think
because expectations were so low I liked
it more than I thought I would but had I
just watched the trailer for it and just
seeing this like you know with all the
fairy dust sprinkling everywhere and
this is gonna change the world and one
woman's story and blah blah blah then
I'd probably be like I'll get the [ __ ]
over yourself you know what I mean I
think our expectations were lowered by
one mark Normand as he tends to do to
people as opposed to you know shooting
him through the moon with all the New
York Times reviews and this is a
remarkable feat of stand-up comedy the
likes of which we've never seen and it
relaxed yeah exactly Pryor also told a
very very painful story and he was the
funniest guy ever and he made you laugh
through the whole thing but he told very
very painful truths things you're saying
she's what twelve years in and we're
comparing it to that you know what I
mean so I mean she's done something
right yeah she's funny yeah but if I'm
Cameron I'm terrified though at the idea
because you're right about Pryor in his
like personal thing and her and her
personal thing I'm terrified at the idea
of the way people are like yeah Pryor
was my biggest influence like there's so
many comics that say that yeah any comic
that at this point in her career hannah
is like the big influence that pushes
them is terrible well people gonna try
to do what she did they're gonna try to
be just poignant and that's what that
that's the mark of a you know
influential special right but it's also
something where I'm like well I also I'm
hungry for these like punchline heavy
specials because that seems to be lost
on us now is like these like Bam Bam Bam
specials and it's like you almost feel
like agency be on the phone like you got
to see this special this person was
molested you know what I mean you're
like that's like to say oh no yeah
they're covering very tough subjects and
it's like you gotta be funny it's got to
be funny or why would I say it like I
mean if I can't make a joke about it I
shouldn't be talking about it in
stand-up comedy
it's
yeah it's it's so odd cuz it used to be
standing it was the one place where you
would fight for no I know that in theory
this concept isn't funny but my job is
to make a joke about it that is funny
this type of comedy is almost going with
your right that is not funny I'll still
talk about it on stage but I won't be
funny about it and you go like what what
are you what are you doing then yeah
what exactly why are you saying that if
you're not gonna make it funny all right
those are the bits I cut the ones that
aren't funny yeah yeah you trying to but
I look again there's things I don't want
to talk about I just can't then when I
find a way to make them funny I'll talk
about them right but until then I took
that feel like who gives a [ __ ] about my
experience red hair right a slam poetry
book you gotta see this new comedian he
comes out dressed as an aborted fetus
yeah and he talks about how his mother
tried to get rid of him one hour and a
half what Edinboro last year but no one
cares about my experience itself who
gives a [ __ ] everyone has those people
who are not comedian so far worse life
than I have but people care but they
don't care enough to sit through you
talking about it with no jokes on Friday
night at 10:31 it's a comedy show and a
building that says it's the laugh barn
respected to laugh at like I don't watch
I don't watch Hogan's Heroes to learn
about World War 2 right comedian won the
Fringe Festival last year with his story
please give a warm welcome to Papa John
Papa tone yeah you're saying you
couldn't get away with the end of that
set at like chuckles no I mean and again
it's again one person show is great do
it I'm not saying you shouldn't do it
but it's a little bit yeah it's flawed
it's flawed especially when earlier you
say that [ __ ] artists don't create
the zeitgeist they respond to it like
when you say that and then you you say
no I don't know we do not she really did
get fired up didn't she but we don't
have I'm so sick of hearing how
comedians have a responsibility we don't
you really your job is to go up there
and be funny talking about the world and
yourself in and everything in it how you
see fit
that's your [ __ ] job to try to be as
original and funny as you can be that's
it if you have a message
if you're Brian Regan you just want to
be silly great if your email Philips
great what do you want everybody up
there well you got a legit comic if
you're up there talking about silly
things but there could be different
types of comics too like if she was this
is her comedy that's great you know and
then the weekend of Gaffigan and then we
can have easy said Regan like that or
David tell who's absurdist and filthy
and brilliant well that's the beauty of
it yeah but do you really want to see I
don't see everybody being like Jim
Gaffigan we did that benefit show until
immediately gets on stage after Mackay
and goes oh my god I've never seen a
teen shooter with a belly put me down I
liked it I didn't get to watch hear more
about it in his story this summer yeah
yeah took a long time to get over there
I want to I'm gonna take this Ian in
Chicago we're gonna go to this is just
so yes sir Craig and baby
hey buddy and shout out to Stan's
entertainment all the guy's the best
he really is a gem it really is a funky
starting a revolution we get into the
bottom of a lot there's a 16 second clip
on YouTube it shows that chipler might
be stolen from the dirty boys you know
let me wander in this okay yeah I
believe it is true yes absolutely that's
what I did I listen to the Jerky Boys
and I said aha I'll ruin my personal
life with this no the clip you're
talking about Ian the character it's a
gay character that was Jim Norton more
stolen ship that he does and that where
he goes or something he says or subtle
you do this as something let's hear the
clapping yeah n let's hear the clip but
you fought from Daytona or Epcot or
something I don't think you know
geography is something so well that
doesn't sound right
Florida and New York you're being silly
go ahead what you want him to try to
tell us though I know the car it's
blazing to the Jerky Boys
it's very ridiculous for a couple of
reasons but we'll play that entire clip
which is about a three minute phone call
which I may have heard in my life I
don't remember it but again I've
listened to the Jerky Boys so it's
possible that I heard it but chip evolve
ship started out being like assist and
it was in my personal life and I would
do it to annoy my girlfriends and then
it began changing over the
for a second I thought you're saying
chip evolves wait but that that was Jim
rolls and you know the fact that some
was something or some but when you
listen to that whole clip I mean to
think that I listen to that at one point
and then develop chip that's right and
then years later brought that in like
it's just it's silly so to answer your
question of course not in your life what
is let me skip Frank Rizzo and go right
to this this character yeah one is a gay
character and chip is just an aggressive
angry [ __ ] but we'll play the entire
clip of that call you can find it it's
Jerky Boys because I looked for it jerky
boys look for a florida Daytona because
they he mentions Florida Daytona in
there but it's a gay character named
Jack touristy eject [ __ ] that's the
name of the character yeah who is very
funny what you get all silly and [ __ ]
yeah but that's no chip is not it I just
like to [ __ ] dance
yeah it was that yeah I think that one
right there the Florida the tropical
stay right there
ah babies don't play that we break all
right yeah and does that answer your
question at all yeah if you were gonna
maybe stop doing the characters as far
as comedy being dead
hold on when am I going to stop - of
course not are we just uh even why would
he stop doing the character like you
like that literally - people use the
words stolen like I actually think like
you think that i sat there went home
that's a great line it's more like the
situation where it's like you heard it
you said that in the past that you don't
watch Tommy that's why I don't watch
comedy but this is it's not like I had a
gay character well it's not like chip is
going oh my god I gotta go down there
and do this it was like he just said
something in the context of a bigger
call and we'll play the entire call and
you listen to that and you think I
listen to that call and then came up
with this character years ago in my
personal life and then brought it on the
air and then changed it it doesn't make
sense so of course I'm not gonna stop
doing the Caribbean do you really think
that Jim took the character the chip is
stolen from Jack tours or are you just
like yeah you like Stern [ __ ] I don't
think he's looking like oh I'm a run
with this this is gonna make me Millions
I think he heard it it sat in the back
of his head he forgot about it he
started doing his mother's girlfriend
doing it on ona and then
eventually he got the show and didn't
realize that he ejected lately giant
coal that you understand have you heard
the entire phone call that entire phone
call tell the truth oh my god oh my god
this is better than like but you jackal
America or something you haven't heard
Ian you have not heard the whole call so
we'll play the whole call you hear what
that character is Jack tours Jack do
more different from chimp it's a gay
character literally two words which or
something yeah or something he's just
talking about it it's not like that's
the whole thing listen to the entire
built on or something no Matt points
it's just something he says like a piece
of garbage it could be in the back of
your head and you could just started
doing it as a gay Ian and then it
evolves and I understand what you're
saying
and I understand that the or something
sounds like ship but I'm telling you
that that's not how the chip character
came to be I'm telling you it's being
truth with you I thought about it I
searched out the clip I'm like let me
listen to the clip and it's simply not
what happened you know it's disgusting
the chip is so successful other people
are working to find chinks in the armor
you can't totally discount the
explanation either and you have to hear
the entire call we'll play it going into
break you know it's a call that I
probably have heard in the past I don't
I didn't remember when I heard it this
time but we'll play you the entire
quality and you can see the tone of the
character it's just a different thing
but don't say you don't need to hear it
of course you do all right but I did not
steal it no I've never I've never heard
something you want aha I'm gonna take
that and run with it Jack tours all
right Ian take a check tours yes as far
as being dead I think a lot of it's like
oversaturation like you've seen Netflix
and turns are up 47 specials in one day
when you've got too much [ __ ] coming out
and it's too political
that's what is making like the market
hard for anybody to have a career well
the problem if you use the problem
Netflix has is they have an entire
planet to represent they have like do
they have comics from Britain and
Scotland and [ __ ] Brazil and all
these because they have the entire
planet to get comedians so they don't
just want American they're trying to
represent everybody and you know what
it's not like HBO where there's a
schedule so they just it's like a
website on television they just taking
[ __ ] and throwing it up and you can
click on it and watch whenever you want
so I don't think they're saturating the
market because it just sits there and
there's the people say oh there's 47
specials how come this produced person
he going there's only four Americans so
it's it's it it's all I should see that
you say that there was I don't know
you're a lot of people gonna see those
specials be like well this this is not
an American or right there if they speak
a different language I'm not even like
the vast majority of the people you will
have never heard of other countries and
yeah yeah yeah all right Ian all right
well thank you guys bye buddy
check tours was he the best you forgot
to yell signs checkers was the best he
was funny he did one call where he was
like responding to a an ad looking for
like background dancers and he did like
like tap-dancing sound effects in the
background and everything and I just
it's like little lines that just stick
with you
the end line of the phone call before
the guy and finally hung up and he was
because I want to dance you [ __ ]